cette maquette futuriste présentant les
équipements d'une ville connectée sera
très prochainement une réalité à
guyancourt bouygues énergie et services
a développé un hyperviseur urbain
objectif mieux gérer tous les
équipements d'une ville
tout se passe dans ce cockpit on a
développé donc une plateforme avec
capgemini qui permet donc à distance de
pouvoir activer piloter les équipements
donc vous donner un exemple si on a un
accident de la circulation
il va falloir passer les feux
clignotants dans la ville il va falloir
rallumer l'éclairage falloir baisser les
bornes
donc tout ça on va pouvoir le faire
depuis un seul outil et de façon très
synchronisée en très peu de temps dans
les prochains mois dijon métropole sera
la première à expérimenter cette ville
du futur
d'autres agglomérations seraient
également intéressés saint quentin en
yvelines compte bien devenir dans un
avenir proche une smart city bien
évidemment on est tout à fait partant
pour travailler sur des expérimentations
et surtout tout ce qui est équipements
connectés pour faciliter la vie des
citoyens pour ce projet imaginé par
bouygues énergie et services compter une
enveloppe d'un peu plus de 100 millions
d'euros
cela comprend l'installation de
l'hyperviseur urbain mais aussi la
maintenance des équipements pendant 12
ans assure-toi noter les économies
qu'ils vont avoir à côté donc on est sur
15 millions d'économies sur la facture
énergétique
et puis on est encore sur plein d'autres
économies la maintenance les équipements
qui est divisé par deux des métropoles
plus intelligente mais aussi plus
durable voilà le pari de bouille énergie
et services afin de faciliter le
quotidien des citoyens de demain